the conversation on the left revolves
almost exclusively around
identity which is in other words me
narcissism is about me
yeah but you kept talking about
economics
that used to be the central conversation
on the left or in america actually yeah
why why no more uh because the
establishment has learned how to co-opt
identity politics to make
to put the brakes on economic progress
and justice
so they so the joke i do
so if you want to if you want to help uh
i would say if you want to help black
people
nothing would help them more than uh
free college student loan relief and
medicare for all and a living wage
you want to help them that would be the
way to help them uh but
joe biden comes in does none of those
things but he makes juneteenth the
holiday
so do you understand what i'm talking
about i do understand so that
that's they're all it's all signals but
there's no substance
we're signaling that we want to help the
minority community but we're not
actually helping them
so that's what identity politics is it's
a big diversion and the joke i say
you know if it was 1860 the democrats
would be
bragging about their first transgendered
slave owner and so what i'm trying to
tell people is
that when you vote for them when you
vote for somebody inside the democratic
party no matter what they say no matter
what they believe
they're going to go along with nancy
pelosi and nancy pelosi goes along with
goldman sachs and raytheon
so when you're voting for someone inside
the democratic party you're voting for
goldman sachs and raytheon because they
are not standing up to those people
so the idea that we have progressives
inside the democratic party
it's actually more deleterious to the
progressive movement to have them there
why is that jimmy because it gives
people a false impression that there's
somebody in government
fighting for you that there's one of the
parties that are kind of on your side
and they aren't
and the quicker people realize that that
both parties are not on their side they
only serve the oligarchy we are in fact
in an oligarchy your democracy was
stolen way before trump
until that happens we won't ever have
real change
but what about ocasio-cortez she's on
instagram
ocasio-cortez campaigned
on a floor vote on medicare for all and
she campaigned on creating what she
called a ruckus meaning you have to stop
being polite this is a quote you have to
stop being polite
we tried being polite and it got us
nowhere and it wasn't until
we started acting out and speaking
impolitely
that we even created the circumstances
for change
that's what she tweeted so i'm just
doing what she said so i started to put
heat
on people like aoc and rasheed talib
and ro khanna and all the justice
democrats in the squad to force the vote
and they said i was committing violence
against them with my words that's how
scared they got
were you that sounds good you really
telling them
to do what they ran on that's violence
that's how afraid they were
and all the things so they had people
write hit pieces on me in the daily mag
new york magazine newsweek buzzfeed they
tried to shut me down and squelch me
they made me trend on twitter negatively
they but they couldn't shut me up
and they couldn't stop me and they don't
know what to do with me because again
all the usual
they have wikipedia putting smears on me
that i can't get
cnn's calling me it's unbelievable
what's going on just a comedian
a pothead comedian in his garage what
you can do when you want to tell the
truth inside journalism and politics
and you can create a ruckus and i did
and so now everybody sees
that those people are fakers and they're
corrupt
and the reason why i say they're corrupt
is not because they take corporate money
and do the bidding of corporations
but they're doing the bidding of their
own career right their own
self-dealing yeah so if i go along with
the establishment i'm going to get a
book deal i'm going to get speaking fees
and i'm going to be in congress for at
least five years and then i get a
pension for the rest of my life
that is corrupt and that's why they're
not pushing back because nancy pelosi
could come in and crush you
hey we'll fund somebody in a primary to
your left just like she did to joe
crowley aoc right
so that's what they're all afraid of
they're afraid of the power of the
establishment taking away what little
power
and uh that they have in congress hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else